vous devez être M.  Benjamin hé pouvez-vous
me parler de certains de vos
clients précédents Trevor serait mon premier client
enfant a un sens de l'humour unique vous
savez pourriez-vous appeler la fondation make-a-wish
et me dire quelle pipe
Katy Perry
il se réveille en même temps  fois tous les jours il
regarde la télé à la même heure tous les jours il
mange à la même heure tous les jours pour deux
gaufres une saucisse avez-vous arrangé
ce genre de moka gros testicules en
petit pénis
ouais avez-vous apporté les papiers du divorce
je ne suis pas prêt Jim  ça fait deux ans et
demi quel est le nombre magique où
vous vous réveillez et vous êtes enfin prêt
quelle est la chose que vous voulez le plus faire si
vous étiez totalement drôle c'est une carte des attractions
routières les plus lamentables de votre pays la
broche la plus profonde du
monde la plus grande du monde  bovin ce qui vous fait
penser que je vous laisserais emmener mon fils en voyage sur la
route je ne laisserai rien
vous
arriver préparez-vous Slim Jim mordez-le au James
c'est que ce qu'ils disent dans votre pays
vérifiez-le mec le plus grand du monde
bovin
tu bon
ouais ouais ouais
devrions-nous lui donner un tour soit je
m'appelle Ben es-tu partant pour elle je ne suis pas
parfait c'est exactement ce qu'un partenaire
dirait j'ai fini alors merci les parents
ont de la place pour ce que
je veux voir
"  tu es une énorme [ __ ] tu
t'approches trop de Trevor je ne peux pas
te faire faire des promesses que tu ne peux pas
tenir tu me demandes un rendez-
vous oui tu connais mon père d'accord puis-je t'aider
tu sais que ce n'est pas tout à propos de moi  c'est à
propos de toi
je vais appeler à la fondation make-a-wish
je vais demander à katy perry de nous rencontrer au
motel
ce qui a déjà voulu chanter pendant
qu'elle te fait de la cire à tarte